first of all congrats on the series um
i want to commend you guys as someone
who watches a lot of television and a
lot of movies uh it had a few twists and
turns that i absolutely did not see
coming um so
you know
all right sweet yes you've been right
thank you
i don't want to get specific because you
know i don't want to reveal anything to
the audience but before we get into the
series eric i read and this might not be
true that you tried to get wesley to be
in narcos yes
very true i did uh and we had dinner
in marina del rey
area of los angeles and
it didn't work out um because wesley you
know as a guy had a lot going on at the
time and and
you know i was trying you know when you
shoot down in that part of the world
um
you're never quite sure what your spread
is gonna be and we couldn't quite figure
out
dates that lined up properly and and uh
i uh
actually it's funny i had big plans for
the character who wesley was going to
play and when i didn't get wesley i sort
of
abandoned them slightly but so to be
able to come back around and get to work
together on this it was uh it was a real
thrill for me
it would have been very wanted to work
with him one thousand ten thousand
percent
wanted to work with i wanted that
opportunity to work out circumstances
yeah you know for his life
business he's doing big business i'm
doing big business but
you'll get another opportunity
completely i think a lot of people don't
realize scheduling plays a huge part in
hollywood people just don't understand
that part huge
huge how many people contribute to
making it work
to making something that people consider
success considered successful it's
absolutely a collaborative effort and a
miracle in many cases
uh eric an individual question for you
can you sort of talk about the genesis
of this project and you know what it was
about this story that said i want to
make this
uh kevin called me out of the blue i
didn't know him i knew who he was
obviously but i didn't know him
and he was a fan of of narcos and uh and
he
he called me and said that he wanted to
do something different he wanted to
get his hands dirty he wanted to go dark
he wanted to kill someone basically and
uh
and he left me to think about that and
think what version of that would appeal
and it
sort of dovetailed with this
theory i have of the sociopathy of
incredibly successful people
some of them are not all of them but
some of them
i believe are capable of
doing some pretty
dark deeds particularly when they're
they're faced with an existential threat
and and
so
that became
a story of
someone like kevin based on kevin
kidd
and his uh and and and this threat that
he's faced and and what he is willing to
do to protect himself
and it only worked
uh for both kevin and myself
when we stumbled upon sort of this
betrayal uh that that would precipitate
this and on the part of his his brother
and
that
became the the
in a lot of ways the
the key player we didn't have we needed
someone
phenomenal
who would bring not just the the the
gravity
but the authenticity of it and because
it was you know for a challenge kevin's
doing something different and the king
of comedy is one of my favorite
movies ever and and
having met jerry lewis
that is jerry jerry lewis is just
playing jerry in the king of comedy uh
if you know the movie well i don't know
that yeah it's one of my favorites and
that's the real guy and and so i got
caught up in the idea of
telling the story of a real
version of of kevin and kevin to his
credit
really went for it and and wesley when
we
first hooked up and when he realized we
weren't trying to do curb your
enthusiasm and he realized okay you guys
are going to a dark place
i'll go there with you and i'll help you
get there which was the thing we really
needed and and that was sort of the you
know
in a in a nutshell
how that that was the process i think by
which we put this great team together
and and went and made the show
wesley as usual your you know your
greatness and you and kevin together are
have such great chemistry it's
completely believable was this an
immediate like yes for you when you when
you were approached about the material
no
it wasn't and
yes i had doubts yes i thought they were
playing around and i thought it was just
another comedian trying you know having
this this dream of being a dramatic
actor which i don't get yeah so
i thought it was very much curb your
enthusiasm but here's how they hooked me
they told me during the conversation two
things that hooked me one was they said
they wanted to be like mean streets
this is going to be more like mean
streets i was like main street oh okay
well now you got my attention and then
kevin said hey man you know i really
want to do this i'm playing it very
serious i want people to see me in a
different way and i need somebody who
can help me do that i say well okay
well all right if you be serious about
this art because i don't play when it
comes to drama you know i don't paint
drama under any circumstances if you're
serious about it that's right and i got
your back i'm gonna be there the whole
way
from the beginning to the end
and that's how that's how it came about
um wesley you have been famous for a
very long time and i'm just curious no
one really you can't go to school to
learn how to be famous you know like
it's not one of these things but i guess
my thing is if um
what is it sort of how much does the
series sort of capture like that
realistic thing of what goes on behind
the scenes like your circle of friends
and you know like that kind of stuff
authentically and absolutely
correct
yes it is a very nuanced
environment to have fame and fortune and
you happen to be a person that comes
from the inner city where
the frequency of fame and fortune is
rare you don't have a lot of neighbors
you don't have a lot of family members
who even understand
what that's all about and then all of a
sudden it happens to you or it happens
to a
sibling
yeah it's very nuanced and it's very
uh it's a very unique environment and
set of situations that we need and could
benefit from having
schools and programs and the sages that
are the wise
of the of us the wiser of us
actually teach
us how to deal with fame and fortune how
do you manage it what we're taught is
do something good be successful i don't
care what you do if you want to be a
garbage man be the best garbage man that
you could ever be
okay but what happens when you actually
achieve that
how do you sustain it how do you manage
it how do you even communicate with
family and friends
you know this is what's happening
yeah
these parts of the story i could
definitely run into um eric i'm curious
how you decided on seven episodes and
like the episode lengths because the
first episode's like an hour and then
some of the other episodes are you know
like 30 minutes and i'm just curious how
that all came about so originally i
wrote
i wrote it as an hour show
um
and then we
when we got into production we shifted
into half hours
because we found ourselves with sort of
a
you know
cliffhanger at the end of every half
hour something happens that just
takes you in some other direction and i
think it's pretty effective in that
regard
up until fairly recently we were we were
uh
one and two one episode one was two
episodes and we just decided you know
this is netflix we can do whatever we
want we could have
an hour and then we could have 40
minutes and then we could have 25 you
know we could do whatever we wanted and
that was really appealing you know i was
like wow that's cool so that way we can
get to this point at the end of one
where i think once you get to that
that ending of the first episode you
cannot stop watching i don't think i
mean i'm i'm betting that you know
once
that happens you're in and so getting to
that point became
a great place to
to to start to you know to to to leap
and uh yeah it was uh you know it was
again
it's one of the many things that
i feel i could only do with netflix um
you know they've been
so supportive and and and
[Music]
liberating creatively and and that was
another way of like hey why don't we
just do an hour and then we'll launch
into half hours
yeah um i gotta go but i was gonna say
that the the first episode ending was
like wait what
and then you know obviously i had to
finish the series you guys had a
fantastic afternoon steven thank you so
much thanks for the kind words thank you
so much have a great day
you